bueno vamos a concentrarnos en lo que me
conectó en aquel
en aquel momento cuando tenía seis años
como bien describió fue mi primera ola
mi papá era guardavidas y conocí a toda
la gente en la playa entonces lo primero
que hizo ante pararme la toda la
apoyamos el fotógrafo que estaba siempre
dando vuelta por la orilla y me sacó esa
foto que está bastante deteriorada pero
la pudimos salvar eso fue en el año 82
gh 82 y en verdad mi papá me paró en la
tabla y yo del miedo no me animé a
bajarme de la tabla y llegué hasta la
orilla pero cuando llegué a la orilla
sentí algo que no había sentido nunca
y sentí que había descubierto el juego
que más me gustaba jugar
sentí algo que creo que los chicos se
conectan con eso que es cuando jugamos y
nos divertimos tanto que queremos jugar
a eso todos los días
la realidad de la diferente
mi papá se separaron yo me fío ir a
buenos aires con mi mamá y papá sigo
viendo mar de plata y en buenos aires lo
único que hacía era pensar en qué día yo
volverá a mar del plata para surfear mar
de plata me conectaba con mi papá con mi
familia y con un montón de cosas que a
mí me gustaban pero el cerf era como el
eje principal de todo lo que me pasaba
internamente era como algo interno que
me quemaba tanto que no lo podía no
podía mirar para otro lado
en buenos aires jugué al rugby jugué
primero en san josé que era colegio
donde iba y después en alumni hasta los
27 años hasta que termine el colegio y
en el medio asia intención de devolverme
mar de plata y decirle a mi papá de que
me quería venir a mar de plata a vivir
para surfear a la costa y mi papá me
decía que no tenía un hermano en ese
momento de un año más chico que yo que
también surfea pero me decía que hasta
que no termine el colegio no podía venir
a malata yo determino el colegio y
quedarme con mi familia con mi hermano
sobre todo algo que entendí muy bien mi
papá tenía mucha razón
en esas en esos años de días si venías a
mar del plata mi papá me dice una de las
frases que a mí más me quedaron grabadas
que fue
hacer lo que amas y amar lo que haces
el hacer lo que amas estaba clarísimo ya
había encontrado lo que quería hacer o
sea había encontrado lo que amaba y lo
quería hacer todo el tiempo
más adelante entendí la otra parte de la
frase mientras tanto en buenos aires
juego al rugby
y en el rayo aprendí muchos valores que
después los pude trasladar al ser y a mi
vida sobre todo el respeto la
responsabilidad el compañerismo y la
disciplina que quizás en el ser no
estaba en ese momento también instalada
el sueño de ser sofista profesional
estaba bastante lejos de lo que en ese
momento la realidad argentina se vivía
vuelve a mar de plata en el 92 cuando
terminó el colegio como habíamos quedado
con mi papá y empiezo a entrenar todos
los días como sea que esté el mar para
poder lograr ese nivel que me podía dar
la posibilidad de llegar a
a vivir del ser que en algún momento
imposible imposible era en la mente de
todo mi entorno y en un montón de amigos
y compañeros y mucho más en mi familia
en el año 93 me convocan para la
selección juvenil y seis meses antes
perdón dos semanas antes me dicen que
estaba pasado seis meses de categoría y
no podía ir a brasil que en el mundial
en el 94 fui a chile con mucha emoción a
un primer a mi primer campeonato
internacional y fue el peor del equipo
en el mundial del 96
estaba como empezando a vivir mi sueño
en medio eeuu el primer mundial el más
grande de la historia hasta ese momento
y donde se inició el movimiento olímpico
que hoy vivimos
como lo pongo en la foto fue el peor del
equipo
y tenía dos opciones sentir que me
hundía y que se me sueño sé
realmente desaparecía por completo
me podía quedar con los brazos cruzados
y no hacer nada y volver a mar de plata
y empezar a trabajar de nuevo en lo que
estaba trabajando hasta ese momento o
aprender a nadar aprender a surfear
había algo que yo no entendía había algo
que me estaba faltando
y ahí entendí la parte de la segunda
parte la frase de mi papá amar lo que
hace es entonces hacer lo que ha
mostrado clarísimo era mi juego era lo
que yo quería había elegido lo que
quería pero amar lo que haces era hacer
un poco más empezar a entrenar físico
técnico mental cosas que en el ser que
en ese momento no se hacían
y que no tenía referencias tampoco
cambie alrededor de 25 o 26 preparado es
físico pero este con los dados todavía
con cada uno hacíamos cosas diferentes
pesa 80 kilos pesa 272 y así todo el
tiempo
no me podía tocar la punta de los pies
otro me llevaba por el yugo y me tocaba
la punta de los pies tranquilamente y
así fui aprendiendo y alguna forma
empezando a encontrar algunas respuestas
a esto
pero siempre te encontrás con el primero
imposible y el primer imposible yo creo
que está dentro de nuestro
y sin conectarnos con nuestra convicción
de que eso que nos quemaba realmente es
auténtico y viene de adentro y no lo
puede frenar es imposible para el resto
adentro mío a veces también resonaba
será que puedo vivir del ser será que
puedo ser alguna vez campeón argentino
y a poco te vas conectando con eso que
decía a mi papá damas lo que hace es
amar el proceso y soportar todo eso
justamente esfuerzos que tienes que
hacer para poder llegar al nivel que
quieres tener para poder lograr tus
objetivos
pero en 1999 tuve la suerte de ganar por
primera vez mi primer campeonato
argentino
y mi primer medalla panamericana que
durante mucho tiempo fue la única
medalla panamericana en el surf open
a partir de ahí en adelante realmente me
fue muy bien sponsors vivían el ser
dos años después de eso formé mi familia
y de alguna forma volvía de nuevo a
plantearse la idea esta de que ibas a
mantener tu familia surfeando
compitiendo
y yo ya estaba convencido que si
internamente me había convencido de que
sí
como les dije esos años fueron buenos
tuve la suerte de ganar varios torneos
argentinos y en el 2006 ganar por
primera vez el campeonato
latinoamericano en el 2009 tuve la
suerte de ganar por primera el primer
argentino hombre que ganaba una fecha
del circuito mundial profesional un
logro que hasta ese momento era otro
imposible
pero faltaba un imposible que yo creo
que a veces es el más grande el que más
nos cuesta doblegar que es el del
entorno
cuando nosotros nos convencemos
internamente a veces te hay una lucha
entre lo interno y lo externo entre
demostrarle al otro de que realmente lo
que pensás sentís y haces es real y es
así y lo puedes lograr obviamente la
gente que nos quiere tiene miedo que la
pasemos mal que tiene miedo que nos
amargamos nos dé primamos que no lo
logremos
entonces se me ocurrió esta idea de que
era y si yo compensó a mi entorno de que
por donde voy es lo correcto y lo que
quiero es lo que me hace feliz y si yo
soy feliz ellos pueden ser felices
porque cuando yo caiga en mi entorno es
el que me va a sostener
pero la idea más importante ya que
cuando a mí me iba bien abrazaba mi
entorno y nos subíamos todos juntos a
ese a ese logro
creo que de alguna forma lo logré
y ahí viene un nuevo desafío
todo lo que había logrado conmigo ahora
lo quería traspasar a otra gente y ver
si realmente mi sistema lo que había
entendido era así
creamos el centro de enseñanza de
entrenamiento integral del ser que
ningún surfista estaba preparado para
entrenar como nosotros le planteamos
había algunos locos que entrenamos
bastante bien y otros no tanto y de a
poquito empezamos a convencer al entorno
en primero mi familia mis amigos y toda
mi gente para que sigan sosteniendo mi
esfuerzo y después a los chicos a los
padres a las familias de que había la
posibilidad de tomarse el ser un poquito
más serio hace varios años creamos el
centro
la enseñanza entrenamiento y con este
grupo que esté que el año pasado
lograron ocho de los diez títulos en
juego del circuito nacional y no es lo
más importante quizás el logro deportivo
sí es importante obviamente porque ellos
entrenaban con mucha dedicación para
poder lograrlo sino que aparte educamos
alrededor del agua y el ser a 300 350
chicos al año lo estamos haciendo hoy
con charlas de campeones mundiales e
instructivas sobre todo tema de
seguridad y nunca perder de foco que es
lo que nos conectó que es que el ser fe
es un juego que es lo que nos divierte
hacer
lo más importante era convencer a mis
atletas a los chicos que hoy entreno que
el surfista no es un individuo que no
puede vivir solo entrenando solo y
compitiendo contra todos como si fuese
mi enemigo y que tenían que aprender a
entrenar en grupo
esto lo traía yo del rey y lo aprendí
mucho los últimos años que empecé a
practicar su sitio donde en un deporte
de contacto si yo no cuido a mi
compañero no tengo más compañero contra
nada pero a la misma vez la práctica
tiene que ser real los chicos que
entraban al agua competía entre ellos y
sacaban lo mejor de ellos y lo mejor del
otro pero tenían que entender de que son
sus compañeros y que entre ellos todos
sumaban por algo mejor
con todos estos conceptos y los
imposibles
mi hermano hace dos años me dijo
dice os pés hasta una vez en porque es
imposible
y la verdad que no lo había pensado como
él me lo planteo
y si bien en inglés la traducción no
podría ser real pero yo la pola plantea
esta manera hayan posible yo soy la
posibilidad de lograr eso que la mente
de muchos quizás no sea posible
es fácil no no es fácil requiere de un
montón de cosas que justamente hoy lo
escuché hablando a algunos de los
oradores que es involucrarse hasta el
fondo de las cosas para poder entender
todos los principios que manejan esa
actividad o esa
si esa actividad yo estoy realizando
para poder entenderla para poder
justamente llevarla a cabo
practicarla y equivocarme equivocarme
todo lo que más pueda soy el error no no
soy el error yo soy
esa persona intentando aprender para ser
mejor el error es información pues es
tan importante hacer y por eso es tan
importante equivocarse
así es como yo me hacía carne con este
concepto que mi hermano decía de hacerse
uno de la posibilidad de lograr cada
cosa que se plantea
y se me ocurrió que
esta estructura no
que necesitamos tener un maestro para
inspirarnos y volver siempre hacer ese
aprendiz esa mente principiante que
quiere recibir y aprender
que tenemos que dejar un legado de todo
lo que hacemos lo que aprendemos para
poder tras traspasar esa antorcha a la
generación que viene que tiene ganas y
por qué no pensar en querer cambiarle la
vida a alguien con todo lo que vamos
aprendiendo
obviamente mi equipo siempre está
presente
veinte años después siete años después
de mi último título nacional
puede lograr con 43 años salir campeón
de nuevo algo que veía muy lejos casi
imposible y ahí me di cuenta que mi papá
tenía razón en lo último que me dijo lo
difícil llegó a tiempo y lo imposible
sólo un poco más gracias
[Aplausos]